the plan was for me to weaken your
defenses with my Brazen sexuality I
wouldn't say Brazen so much is
completely undetectable I couldn't have
been more obvious I wore single winds or
not I might as well have a signor on my
neck that reads DTF Desiring thorough
fornication no exactly we've ruined our
outfits why will that reignites the
passion because it will force them to
change into clothes which I will have
carefully placed at the top of their
suitcases thus changing them both into a
couple of thirst staps Kevin cner
preparing to descend the master St oh I
see you changed into your
mock turtleneck and you into
your exercise shorts I feel dirty you
feel dirty I do and I love it I'd like
to introduce you to your new assistant
drum roll
please that's your drum roll when a
temple hasn't specified any reasonable
person but default tento well it's
terrible and you ruined a fun thing but
I would still like to introduce you to
Mr Gordon
Lun Mr Mr Gordon
Lunt Gordon you want to come in here oh
I'm so sorry I was just deciding whether
I should just go home the tone and tenor
of your introduction make me worry that
this is a fun office which I would not
enjoy hello I'm captain Raymond hold and
I can assure you this is not a fun
office thank goodness in that case my
interest is renewed here is my resume oh
I'm feeling this are you guys feeling
this Gordon why don't you tell Captain
Holt a little bit about yourself where
to begin I'm 174 cm tall I can type 103
words per minute with an error rate of
1.6% and I recently moved here from
Philadelphia which is the sixth most
populous US city I understand the city
of Philadelphia is co-terminus with
Philadelphia County making it the eighth
largest metropolitan statistical area
yeah Philly's cool isn't it fun just
telling each other facts yes well I
think I have all the information I need
thank you for coming in Mr L my
pleasure so looks like operation nasty
is a full-on success huh you mean
operation nasty sex lot's it was about
night with didn't you see him flirting
with me no I most definitely did not and
you're a blind man and aov to boot did
you see his tie a single Windsor the
easiest not to undo why bother wearing
any clothes at all I think you badly
misread that interaction please he did
everything but lick his lips and purr
get rid of him and bring to someone who
can keep it in their slacks maybe you
should let them know you've been missing
him huh well might be worth a
shot what did you just do I texted him a
picture of my penis like you suggested
no I meant for you to call him and tell
him you've been thinking about him why
didn't you say I thought it was
understood hold on he's writing back oh
what did he say it's a linkor graph it's
a scatter plant with a very robust data
set well that escalated quickly do you
hear there's a barrel making exhibit at
the brookin Museum of Industry
yes has he no shame the door was open I
think he wanted people to hear yeah I
stole those coins can't believe you
bought that old story they
underestimated you Randy just as they
underestimated Raymond Holt now you you
guys haven't been that great to me
either well you got to teach people how
you want to be treated Randy Dr Phil rip
the point is Captain Holt solved the
case when no one else could he's
actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel Alistair you're an
embarrassment really well at least I've
never confused St Augustine with boethus
oh who gives a rat's ass about boethus
Wesley what are you doing Kevin I'm
creating a Kur fuffle oh damn sure my
husband is a hot piece of ass but he is
so much more than just that Raymond Holt
is as smart as anyone in this department
but he chooses to use his intelligence
to make our City a better
place one day I hope to live up to the
standard you set you make me want to
have a wetter brain oh
Kevin y'all are hella specific look at
us three Rogue cops taken on a case the
commissioner told us to drop find up
your jacket set up straight judge
Mandell has a reputation for being
strict and proper all right no worries
I'll just act like you say something so
I can get the Cadence of your voice down
I will not not perfect I will not I will
not I will
not have a seat detective I will not
excuse me uh sorry I meant out of
respect I will choose to stand sit I
will
not this looks like it was filled out by
a toddler now we're going to have to go
through this point by Point Justice
cannot be rushed but could it be gently
nudged into hypers speed I take it
you're the
toddler excuse me a moment mhm this is
going terribly new
plan I'm going to charm
her oh no I'm sorry I had to take that
you got to do what you got to do Captain
Raymond
Hol what's
[Music]
up
W oh you were not a corn crake but you
heard the call yes it was Majestic corn
crake oh I can't believe it finally spot
a corn CR and my eyes are swollen shut
it's okay Kevin I'll describe it to you
okay have you ever seen a duck Peralta I
got this okay the beak color is Pantone
4685 C the wing is Pantone 2322 C
spotted with 4515
C the tail is Pantone 7525 C with bands
of
419c my my oh Kevin the throat Panton
C oh
Raymond those are some hot
pantones look at that they put the
Sherry barrels right up front G I hate
it when museums Pander to the tourists
oh I think you need to check your bag
Gordon it's a small price to pay to make
sure the barrels are protected my
thoughts exactly the package is headed
your way copy that this better work I'm
debasing myself out here what must
people
think oh I'd prefer to discuss this
matter in private anything you have to
say to me you can stay in front of bral
very well I've been sent here to spy on
you what I am truly shocked we are both
shocked commissioner Kelly knows you
recruiting a team of captains to oppose
him he asked me to find out who they are
but I've decided I won't help him why
not because I've fallen in love with you
what that is truly shocking for real
this time what so nice of you to stop by
bye Kevin enjoy your day I hope it's
productive thank you Raymond I hope your
day is productive as well PDA in the
office my my couldn't help myself I got
to hand it to you captain that was some
ceremony it wasn't difficult I simply
said what I wish had been said when
Kevin and I got married well then I
never would have heard your hilarious
efficient officient quip you're right I
regret
nothing but all this does make me think
I might enjoy a more festive expression
of our commitment to one another are you
suggesting we hold an honest to goodness
wedding nothing too elaborate we're not
the Kardashian wests after all they are
a musician and a celebrity personality
who recently wedding yes yes I know they
were answers on Jeopardy I think you
mean
questions you guys are fun can I help
you I'm just trying to work up the nerve
to see her see who my female wife
Crystal I was cheating on her with a
waitress from Wings named Jamie
Lynn one night when I was philandering
Crystal caught me kissing Jam
Lynn's heavy breasts she flew into a
rage and now she's serving five years
for aggravated assault hey I'm sorry to
hear that yeah thanks man when we first
got married I thought of it primarily as
a legal contract which is why I memorize
the entire federal tax code
30177 1-18 definitions pertaining to
marriage and yet he can't remember Max
name but I finally learned what marriage
really is it's not something you can
memorize or an equation you can solve
for it's the feeling you get when you
look in your partner's eyes and that
feeling is all that
matters which is why I will now Purge
tax code
30177 1-18 from my memory so that I will
have room to remember this moment
forever it's done it's funny when we
first met we had some good
times looks like we both want that
stapler seems that way based on what
happened so when did it all go south
1989 I was up for a big promotion which
would have fast-tracked my career W
offered to write a letter on my behalf
but instead she torpedoed me because of
something that happened the night before
she was attor it
in
mlin
would you care for a drink I'd love one
I'm sure you can tell I'm quite drunk
I've had a couple to build up the nerve
I think we both know what I'm about to
say
Raymond I don't think we need to say
anything I'm gay that's what I was going
to tell you well
then she sabotaged my career because I
refused to bed her